okay we're doing I'm likely Valentine
here it's your boy psychobabble with
Donald Trump and I'm a man strong let's
go side of this match let go say this
batch LOL him Sam okay ma'am eyes I die
die die die unlike me Valentine oh where
is a mercy she's in the mark-up playing
with this guy um data show on map no
it's like mix today park street station
like I was there mm mm Oh Oh my God why
she had convoy is because he's a
different color than him he's darker
that's my stub while I see on the head
that's a sad as she was look at the hand
jobs you know that's how sad you'd never
give [ __ ] the left hand that's my
style okay let's get in there let's get
in there got a gut gut
pre-moistened that's what I am and I
make the ladies come pre-moistened okay
joining skinny Malone's crew was the
best decision without me hello sir care
for some change in America well this guy
is like a lot of help did that kind of
sucks that I'm like 10 knife in the face
have a sad mass tonight you get good
good i like it bunion good good hello
sir I'm here to save yourself you know I
don't like the way he looks Top Chef
do you think things like a hack now yeah
I like those in Sultana I like that
thing I have a really good wears a 10
millimeter there we go just a powerful
they get law health right here you
Chanel any bit that Jesus sorry guys
sorry to sneeze like that tough [ __ ] on
upstairs mmm I'm here for your women I'm
here for you when im here for your women
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah hey we're
getting away
why is it for it I need a head shot
that's just what I do
oh ok I don't know why the fully
automatic weapons are like not at like
one first person shooter style okay okay
okay good good good good good mm yes it
like a cat man I go blow up the ham yeah
guys got done we're all friends here
wow I just saw something at murder in
front of my ass okay quick same more are
you about Tyler are you he's gonna bolt
right or something shot a single sorry I
see I guess good good I'm gonna [ __ ]
kallio batch car i'm taking a corn
get me in here
okay can I get Ken
I'm here to save my friend dan LA yes
cuz i'd like to know wow man when i
first played this game i was like i
thought this yet just [ __ ] weird the
bad system but it's kind of cool is that
I got a [ __ ] he'll die
mmm I got questioned why the hell would
anyone build a boat out of a subway
station okay that's every yo TIFF a man
with a cute one day here I love to hear
that's good let's say okay good and then
I could stay there that guy yes very I
you know I like playing fair you know no
[ __ ] tarp areas but I don't need it
disgaea have to get [ __ ] out where'd
you go
Red Cat Cat I hear cool here Gord Oh
some to sit behind me right now that guy
something I don't like how slow it is
like he like takes his time to fire just
like halls is you know okay sextube am
so another dude oh [ __ ] there is paint
me in the head
yes that's a killer taking a core should
he get no I was gonna suck any got any
can't like fast travel in this ship well
it's like Walter all this it she knows
it she knows okay are you doing in their
valentine feeling hungry wanna snack
keep talking me head whatta [ __ ] this
dead out how he's gonna bump you off
don't give me that crap Valentine what
hello Dana where is the password that's
right there Jane was pretty easy okay I
can't get get good
you know he's a robot now ah my knight
in shining armor question is why does he
come all this way risk life and limb old
private eye it's good question my son
sean is missing he was kidnapped but I
don't know who took him or where they
went missing kid huh well you came to
the right man I've been cooped up in
here for weeks turns out the runaway
daughter I came here to find wasn't
kidnapped anyway you got troubles and
I'm Dwight cares can hear wait this kind
of could stop yes speech okay I just see
something interesting here mm-hmm excuse
me so slow i'm just gonna [ __ ] around
out the way I came oh wait no he is a
[ __ ] Craig's it right ya see hey get
out of here I got it okay
okay good see I don't [ __ ] around I come
to game like this huh so said I like
over there uh-huh was he carrying a baby
rattle gonna [ __ ] that but I'm not gonna
judge I'm kind of [ __ ] up in my own
way sure we got here this doors on the
fritz let me see if i can get it open
Hackett hack it yeah look at this hacker
there we are he's an uber on the other
side exit that okay okay let's get out
of here oh [ __ ] oh shut up it's just
tuck it as arm like a hundred times
mm-hmm mm-hmm okay where I wish I mean
man what's he doing down here now he's
just taking a sweet off or something
work
here though checking my time Licata hell
for some reason right is it just me okay
I'll take so many apples thank you oh
jeez this guy's angry better stop them
from [ __ ] hitting me look I'm right here
you don't like that Thanks is that ok so
we are ticketed think huh oh I'm like
kinda emo [ __ ] it hey what's a 1 i'll
see you though shotgun now uh I like I
could use like the [ __ ] gun hate this
gun
where's your [ __ ] whiskey and the
nursery it's [ __ ] out love facet saves
in this game okay this guy's still
taking a second time
you find out where the [ __ ] he is where
is he I'll be sucking upstairs I get
over there did I haven't go the right
way he's just going up no it's gone down
it's not that way okay so happy burlas
right what is that blowtorch all right I
had a fair how to [ __ ] find this did
he is one slope that is for sure ok I'm
on the right way now exit dumb he'll
just keep all night with something
thanked it done she's over here ok ok
I'm dying up i skin him alone and the
rest of his boys are waiting for us
somewhere the names ironic but don't let
that fool you he's dangerous
i hack that huh another lock door hack
at a cat but I hear big fat footsteps on
the other side once we step through this
door get ready for anything hello this
bad boy out that's Dennis I gotta pee
out my dick hole Jesus ha a stretch oh
my gum being in takes a bandeau me bondo
me bond on what are you doing shoot up
my guys you had any idea how much this
is gonna set me back I wouldn't be here
if it weren't for your two-timing game
skinny not at Ella to write home more
often 00 little bad she's hottest a
change you got beat up by a girl I'll
just run back home to Daddy shella
should have left it alone Nikki this
ain't the old neighborhood in this fault
I'm king of the castle you hear me and I
ain't letting some private dick shut us
down now that I finally got a good thing
going I told you we should have just
killed him but then you had 20 chances
stupid crap o times doll I'm handling
this skinny Malone's always got things
up second behind their disgusting huh
Valentine mustn't Roddy oh yeah when
does ignoring me
Darla listen to me you're right what
doll up wow that was really weird how
much you changed where should have been
all this time this is goodbye for us oh
come on Nikki see a [ __ ] murder man
now you and your friend cost me my girl
my friend here just did you a favor
skinny you always did have bad taste in
women now that she's not around to feed
that temper of yours maybe you'll see
sense and let us walk you still owe me
for two weeks in the hole smug
overconfident ass yeah yeah all right
you get to the count of 10 I still see
your face after that I'm gunning both of
you down don't go okay okay Nana
56
what is up without that i exploded him
cut and out this way I can't like all
speech jacks and it's entertaining hello
sir face a little [ __ ] up but I'll
bother you I fixed it for you good thing
I've out that has no idea what happened
even though he's a detective you know
that we just murdered his hands
change this like 10 miles to get out
good he knows gun Jesus in this way the
girl can't like changing Ryan cuz the
guys like ass right now oh it takes like
10 years when i lo the outside Jesus
he's gone on here how Sarah Sarah
hmm what is ass chinese ass
look at that commonwealth sky never
thought anything so naturally ominous
could end up looking so inviting thanks
for getting me out how did you know
where to find me anyway many people knew
where I went Sally your secretary le she
did give her a rash yes I'll give her
something that's resting about your son
Shaw I want you to come to my office in
diamond city I'll meet you there see you
and diamonds okay all right thanks guys
that was unlucky von seiner valve a long
time like always get my little psycho
and I'll jump and strong